[Applause]
they're america's greatest import
what is black people wait a minute now
hold on one second hold on one second
hold on one second
no no let's make the argument are black
people
america's greatest importance is there a
better
import from anywhere in black
let's think about in terms of
cultural significance is there any more
potent and powerful culture than black
american culture in terms of like it's
spread around the world
right now and who benefits from that
mad i try to make this a positive it is
yeah but think about who benefits from
that it's a positive you know
benefits from that america benefit when
when you see little japanese kids
dressing like
black kids from new york or l.a
doing breakdancing doing all this [ __ ]
that's america that benefits from that
that's colonialism in a weird way it's
cultural colonialism yeah doing the acon
thing and just saying like oh yeah but
just ignore the whole slavery party
no no no no no no no no no no i'm saying
america no no i'm saying america
was very lucky to get black people what
listen
slavery horrible slavery horrible but
you have to admit that it
undeniably i think this is the argument
that so many black people make is like
yo
we built this ship for free okay right
like so if we're talking about
who benefited the most america benefited
way more
like from slave labor than any other
import okay think about the main thing
about like
the insane the amazing amounts of money
and wealth that was built
off of free labor that's all i'm saying
okay and like leverage this globally you
took it negatively i know but it's still
not something
i'm happy about like i'm not i'm not
gonna brag like oh yeah we're america's
greatest import
i was just making an observation i would
never tell you how to feel about
honestly i was just trying to defend
something that sounded crazy i know
i think i did a pretty good job of it
though i didn't
watch that guys
but for real though that is an
interesting argument can you think of
one other import
wine
than black people first of all who
whines more
i ain't seen no chardonnays like white
lives matter
white ones
[Laughter]
unlike you wine has good legs
now if a black people got great legs bro
but generally but not really speaking
not out yeah
i got the puerto rican stuff yeah we got
puerto ricans
legs is built for merengue
my hips don't lie okay but no let's
think about that no
i think it's interesting
okay america's greatest export go
i already know it i already democracy
huh democracy some might say it was
imported but i'll i'll let you rock
on that you could argue
that's a french import you could argue
ain't nothing a french import
even the fries honestly same with wine
bro
well well that's important i think i
would have to say america's greatest
export
sugar
there is no dessert without america
america changed the world
sugar change the world did we didn't we
just
conquer hawaii so we could have the
sugar that they were already had that
was one thing that we did
but that's part of america and i think
sugar cane existed before and was used
before
only in the americas did not exist in
europe or any of that kind of [ __ ]
sugar mark
look at any place we were doing this the
other day mark and i were sitting here
we're out there and we were starting to
go through desserts because we got what
was the dessert
mango sticky yeah mango sticky rice then
we're like oh it's just mango and rice
and then sugar all over it
and we're like oh wait a minute sugar is
from where mark
uh the sugar plantation the sugar
plantations
okay i'm gonna need a little bit more
going on
hey guys no facts for a second feeling
no factors
you look at the facts in the meantime
andrew you guys are feeling so i'm
trying to
america has sugar cane all right okay i
think india did too
no india didn't have sugarcane he did no
you didn't
you didn't have sugar cane let me know
when y'all want facts
all right what when you're ready for
facts we can go over it first
we'll go to the black guy for facts come
on whoa
come on
that was racial i don't know if it was
racist
but it was it was racial it was rachel's
gotta come dressed like the mask and all
of a sudden
it's a wild outfit that is why is it
even hindu
it's indian huh indian but that's just
straight up indian maybe some fusion
[ __ ] well i made the point that you got
gotta be grateful to the british a
little bit
for giving him buttons but we're
assuming you guys did buttons this is
again
feelings no facts absolutely we did
buttons yeah you'll just be wrapping
yourself up
one point that's what i was saying
and then you try to do some cute [ __ ]
where you show off your midriff even
though you all got the worst midriffs on
the planet
you guys take that
y'all got the words mid drifts because
y'all either too fat
or you're so skinny that you got the
extended bellies what about the top
drifts
we got good ass top drifts yo y'all got
heavy dudes